three things never come back
time word and opportunity
therefore do not waste time choose words
and do not miss the opportunity
if they spit at you behind your back
it means you're ahead of them
we have two lives
and the second begins when we realize we
only have one
the disease of men is that they neglect
their own fields and go to weed the
fields of others
before you embark on a journey of
Revenge dig two graves
there are one thousand lessons in defeat
but only one in Victory
if you are depressed you are living in
the past
if you are anxious you are living in the
future
if you are at peace you are living in
the present
the Journey of a thousand miles
begins with a single step
we take greater pains to persuade others
that we are happy and endeavoring to
think so ourselves
a healthy man wants a thousand things
a sick man only once won
work on clearing your thoughts if you do
not have bad thoughts there will be no
bad Deeds
the man who says he can and the man who
says he cannot
are both correct
learn as if you constantly feel you lack
your knowledge
and as if you are constantly afraid of
losing your knowledge
don't criticize your neighbor's roof for
a lot of snow
when your door is not clean
if you hate
then you have been defeated
it is more shameful to distrust our
friends than to be deceived by them
appear weak when you are strong
strong when you are weak
he who flatters a man is his enemy
he who tells him of his faults is his
maker
to see what his right to not do it is
the worst cowardice
what the caterpillar calls the end
the rest of the world calls a butterfly
the person attempting to travel two
roads at once will get nowhere
he who is satisfied with his lot is rich
the noble person uses things
the lesser man is used by things
a leader leads by example
not by force
even the finest sword plunged into salt
water
will eventually rust
man's nature is evil
goodness is the result of conscious
activity
in the midst of Chaos
there is also opportunity
to lead people
follow them
when anger Rises
think of the consequences
to know your enemy
you must become your enemy
if you are the smartest person in the
room
then you are in the wrong room
opportunities multiply as they are
seized
get rid of the desire to have
the funniest people are the saddest ones
when I let go of what I am
I become what I might be
the man who moves a mountain
Begins by carrying away small stones
who wishes to fight must first count the
cost
and weak wins over hard and strong
be extremely subtle even to the point of
formlessness
be extremely mysterious even to the
point of soundlessness
thereby you can be the director of the
opponent's fate
true words are not pleasant
pleasant words are not true
what the Ancients called a clever
fighter
is one who not only wins
but excels in winning with ease
live for the praise of others and you
will become their prisoner
people in ancient times did not like to
talk much
they considered it the shame for
themselves not to keep up with their own
words
you have to believe in yourself
[Music]
there is nothing softer and more
flexible than water
but try to resist it
was all the answers has not been asked
all the questions
if the mind is willing the flesh could
go on and on without many things
watch your thoughts they become your
words
watch your words they become your
actions
watch your actions
they become your habits
watch your habits they become your
character
watch your character
it becomes your destiny
great results can be achieved with small
forces
the wise man avoids all extremes
great is the man who has not lost his
childlike heart
we accept advice and drops but we
distribute it in buckets
Ponder and deliberate before you make a
move
when people know a lot it is difficult
to manage them
if what one has to say is not better
than silence
then one should keep silent
ultimate Excellence lies not in winning
every battle
but in defeating the enemy without ever
fighting
nature does not hurry yet everything is
accomplished
what you do not want done to yourself
do not do to others
wheels of Justice grind slow but grind
fine
man dies from birth
study the past if you would Define the
future
it is easy to love your friend
but sometimes the hardest lesson to
learn
is to love your enemy
knowledge is the treasure and practice
is the key to it
you can overcome bad habits only today
not tomorrow
who knows doesn't say
who speaks doesn't know
you can't trust a man who has nothing to
lose
choose a job you love and you will never
have to work a day in your life
plan for what is difficult while it is
easy
do what is great while it is small
whoever talks a lot often fails
life is really simple
but we insist on making it complicated
if he sends reinforcements everywhere
it will be weak everywhere
life is a series of natural and
spontaneous changes
don't resist them
that only creates sorrow
let reality be reality
let things flow naturally forward in
whatever way they like
think of tomorrow
the past can't be mended
an enemy is a friend who knows too much
about you
victory over others gives strength
victory over oneself gives fearlessness
give a bowl of rice to a man and you
will feed him for a day
teach him to grow his own rice
and you will save his life
disorder came from order
fear came from Courage
weakness came from strength
do not seek otherwise you will lose
do not seek and you will find
it does not matter how slowly you go as
long as you do not stop
the skillful artist will not alter his
measures for the sake of a stupid
Workman
beware of sugar that is mixed with
poison
Beware of the fly that sat on a dead
snake
a man dies easily because he has too
much will to live
who does not know the evils of War
cannot appreciate its benefits
time is a created thing
to say I don't have time is like saying
I don't want to
a noble person blames himself and an
insignificant person blames others
therefore
just as water retains no constant shape
so in Warfare there are no constant
conditions
fill your bowl to the brim and it will
spill
keep sharpening your knife
and it will be blunt
friends are the siblings God never gave
us
it is better to light one small candle
than to curse the darkness
every animal with blood in its veins and
horns on its head
will fight when it is attacked
the one who knows and pretends not to
know is on top
who without knowledge pretends to be
knowledgeable
he is sick
tell me and I will forget
show me and I may remember
involve me and I will understand
care about what other people think and
you will always be their prisoner
getting something done is like digging a
well
you can dig a well 70 feet deep
but if you don't hit water it's just an
abandoned well
even a loss can turn into a profit or
profit can turn into a loss
the feeling of right or wrong is the
beginning of wisdom
there is no crime greater than having
too many desires
there is no disaster greater than not
being content
there is no Misfortune greater than
being covetous
attack the evil that is within yourself
rather than attacking the evil that is
in others
be attentive to your thoughts
they are the beginning of actions
to complain about an unpleasant thing is
to double the evil
to laugh at it is to destroy it
you can always rise above those who
offend you
by forgiving them
by three methods we may learn wisdom
first by reflection
which is noblest
second by imitation which is easiest
and third by experience
which is the bitterest
the truth is not always beautiful
nor are beautiful words the truth
people are distressed by their inability
to do it
the problem however is simply that they
don't do it
you are controlled by the one who makes
you angry
be content with what you have
rejoice in the way things are
when you realize there is nothing
lacking
the whole world belongs to you
roads were made for Journeys not
destinations
Never Say Never
because the days go by so fast and
nothing stays the same
your life is what your thoughts make it
we gain by losing
lose by gaining
no matter how busy you may think you are
you must find time for reading
or Surrender yourself to self-chosen
ignorance
when I free myself from who I am
I become who I can be
Happiness is when you are understood
great Happiness is when you are loved
real Happiness is when you love
Temperance is the first step of virtue
which is the beginning of moral
perfection
sometimes we see a lot but do not notice
the main thing
the snow goose needs not bathed to make
itself White
neither need you do anything but be
yourself
the wise man is one who knows what he
does not know
respect yourself and others will respect
you
if you lack Faith then existence does
not believe in you
what is evil to one at one time
becomes good at another time to somebody
else
I have just three things to teach
simplicity
patience compassion
these three are your greatest treasures
being deeply loved by someone gives you
strength while loving someone deeply
gives you courage
the way is near
but men seek it to far
it is in easy things but men seek for it
in difficult things
New Beginnings are disguised as painful
endings
forget injuries never forget kindness
so the unwilling Soul sees what's hidden
and the ever wanting Soul sees only what
it wants
there is Beauty in everything
but not everyone can see it
the way of Truth is like a great Road
it is not difficult to know it
the evil is only that men will not seek
it
a man must not be without shame
for the shame of being without shame is
shamelessness indeed
be bent and you will stay straight
be empty and you will remain complete
be worn out and you will stay new
the man who chases two rabbits
catches neither
health is the greatest possession
contentment is the greatest treasure
confidence is the greatest friend
a trail through the mountains if used
becomes a path in a short time but
if unused
becomes blocked by grass in an equally
short time
it is easy to hate
and it is difficult to love
this is how the whole scheme of things
works all good things are difficult to
achieve and bad things are very easy to
get
the whole being knows without learning
sees without looking
and detains without doing
Learning Without thought is labor lost
thought without learning is perilous
try your best to be to others as you
would wish to be treated yourself
and you will find that this is the
shortest way to benevolence
success is as dangerous as failure
hope is as Hollow as fear
people of higher morality do not
consider themselves moral
therefore they have the highest morality
if you make a mistake and do not correct
it
this is called a mistake
a sage who wants to be above people puts
himself below them
wanting to be ahead of them he becomes
behind
the one who offends you takes away your
negative energy and gives you his
positive energy
what is a good man but a bad man's
teacher
what is a bad man but a good man's job
learn as if you were not reaching your
goal and as though you were scared of
missing it
if you are alone for a long time
soon you will accept loneliness
you will never know your potential if
you are afraid to be alone
you cannot open a book without learning
something
along absence of sex turns a person into
a neurotic
by remaining true to yourself without
seeking to compare and compete
you will achieve Universal respect
if someone wants to offend you greatly
then it is even worse for him
a man with outward courage dares to die
a man with inner courage dares to live
our greatest glory is not and never
falling
but in Rising every time we fall
a great man clings to the essential and
leaves the insignificant
he does everything in truth but
he will never rely on laws
worry not that no one knows you
seek to be worth knowing
if you aren't afraid of dying
there is nothing you can't achieve
the superior man is modest in his speech
but exceeds in his actions
whoever undertaking a business hurries
too quickly to achieve a result will do
nothing
he who carefully finishes his work
as he began will not fail
the man who asks a question is a fool
for a minute
the man who does not ask is a Fool For
Life
the more you don't have sex
the less you want it
truth uttered before its time is always
dangerous
when true virtue is lost good nature
appears
when good nature is lost Justice appears
when Justice is lost decency appears
the rules of decency are only the
semblance of truth and the beginning of
all disorder
if there is no dull and determined
effort there will be no brilliant
achievement
to recognize your insignificance is
empowering
friendship is one mind in two bodies
he who knows the measure is satisfied
with his position
pride in excess bring to bring disaster
for man
sometimes you must yield in order to win
and sometimes maintaining a low Place
leads you to win